TO OUR NEXT GAME, PAY THE BILLS.
PAY THE BILLS.
THIS IMAGE WAS TRENDING ON IMGUR
TODAY, DEMONSTRATING THE SHEER
BRUTALITY OF WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
MAN COMES FACE-TO-FACE WITH
NATURE.
OH, [BLEEP], IT LOOKS LIKE YOU
DUCKED WITH THE WRONG ANIMALIA.
THE AUTHOR CAPTIONED IT, "I
SHOULDN'T HAVE FED THAT ONE DUCK
YESTERDAY."
AND THESE DUCKS LOOK LIKE THEY
MEAN BUSINESS.
SO, COMEDIANS, I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO COME UP WITH AS MANY DUCK
DEMANDS AS YOU CAN.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK.
AND BEGIN.
(BELL DINGS)
HORATIO.
>> THOSE DUCKS ARE QUACK
ADDICTS.
>> HARDWICK (CHUCKLING): OH!
GODDAMN IT!
UGH, POINTS!
(BELL DINGS)
MATT.
>> WHY IS DONALD THE ONLY DISNEY
CHARACTER WITH A SPEECH
IMPEDIMENT?
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
MATT.
>> DOWN WITH DOWN PILLOWS, UP
WITH HUMAN HAIR PILLOWS.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, POINTS.
FINALLY, SOMEONE'S BRAVE ENOUGH
TO SAY IT.
POINTS. JERRY.
>> QUACK, QUACK, LET US [BLEEP]
YOUR WIFE.
>> HARDWICK: OKAY, I GOT TO
CHARGE YOU FOR THAT, BUT I GUESS
I CAN JUST PUT IT ON YOUR BILL.
(GROANING)
>> WHOA!
>> OH!
>> HARDWICK: I SEE EVERYTHING IS
IN ORDER HERE!
(BELL DINGS)
HORATIO.
>> PLEASE QUIT DROPPING DEAD
PROSTITUTES IN THE LAGOON.
(BUZZER SOUNDS)
OR WE'LL [BLEEP] IN YOUR EYES
AND MOUTH.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
THAT WAS AMAZING.
GIVE HIM POINTS.